hi i'm danny ceo and welcome to a brand
new episode of do
just one thing
is there anything sweeter and better
than a homemade hot fudge sundae
well if that sounds intimidating and
almost overwhelming
what if i tell you you can make it in
two ingredients
in one easy step and it's the world's
best hot fudge sundae
so the way that we start is that you
need a bowl
it's very simple you're gonna love this
recipe and what i use is maple syrup
so what we love about maple syrup it's
gonna give that hot fudge
that viscosity that you want sort of
like that ooey
gooey liquid shininess that you have in
here
and the secret is to do about
one cup of maple syrup two cups if
you're cooking for a crowd
and three cups if you're watching movies
by yourself
and then you take two packets of hot
cocoa mix so any brand is completely
fine
you don't have to get the fancy french
chocolate cocoa oh chocolate or anything
this is just a regular
supermarket variety and you sprinkle
your two hot cocoa packets in here i try
to avoid the ones that have the
marshmallows in there
i find it doesn't really work to make a
hot fudge if possible
and then you take a whisk and you just
whisk it together
the last step is you take your maple
syrup hot cocoa mixture
and you just heat it up until it starts
to simmer just a little bit around the
edges
and then turn off the heat and i'll show
you this is what it looks like
before you heat it up it just looks like
very liquidy almost like chocolate milk
this is not
a good hot fudge recipe but what happens
is when you heat it up
and then you let it cool look how it
just
emulsifies into the richest
darkest most decadent sticky
hot fudge and one of the nice things
about this recipe
is when hot fudge is too scorching hot
you ever notice
that when you ladle it on ice cream
everything just melts down very quickly
you have to eat it as quickly as
possible
with this one it can still be warm but
it can also
let you enjoy every
last morsel as the hot fudge drips down
the edges
covers the ice cream how good does that
look
and then i noticed that it was two
ingredients that
happened a little whipped cream
and there you have it in a matter of
minutes
you have probably one of the best
homemade
hot fudge recipes using just maple syrup
cocoa mix
and a spoon
[Music]
you seriously have to try this it's the
best thing ever if you're going to make
this hot fudge recipe be sure to tag the
drew barrymore show in your instagram
post and don't forget
oh gosh it's so good don't forget
to check out the jewberrymart show.com
for a lot more recipes and ideas
just like this and you can find recipes
as amazing and sweet and decadent like
this in my magazine
naturally danny ceo which you can find
on newsstands
i just want another bite oh my gosh
thank you guys do just one thing
or eat the whole sunday yourself
you